[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
chaque matin et 10 bars et agriculteurs
effectué ses livraisons de fruits et
légumes dans les commerces de petite île
je remonte sur l'exploitation mais on va
achever les planter vos portes et
occuper
du chant
[Musique]
là je me suis installé en 1988
comme vous voyez des fraises après ma
plus grosse culture c'est la carotte par
watt après c'est ça ma brède échoue un
petit peu de tout pour cet agriculteur
indépendant la plus grande difficulté
rencontrée aujourd'hui et l'importation
des produits
en effet la réunion importe environ 16
milles tonnes de fruits et dix neuf
mille tonnes de légumes accord droite à
gauche ou à la réunion et nous on a créé
une association premier carottes dont je
suis le président c'est pour défendre ma
fille et à carole parce que certains
moments la filière la carotte est prêt
disparaître sur les étals de la de lieux
du coup on a fait une affaire une
journée d'un une journée d'information
sur mon terrain on avait invité pas mal
de gens et on avait fait des
dégustations de jus
adieu fermé pour moi c'est s'il
reconnaissait la carotte d'importation
avec la chorale pays sens il n'y a pas
photo et du cou et du coup depuis depuis
cette période or on a eu un regain un
regain de 2
des consommateurs de consommer de la
carotte pays suite à une décision prise
en séance plénière le conseil
départemental met en place une aide
spécifique qui a pour but de soutenir la
production locale de valoriser les
produits des agriculteurs et de
maintenir leur filière on sait que sur
certaines productions comme l'ail
on a plus d'importation que la
production locale
donc là aujourd'hui c'est surtout une
aide qui va permettre d'augmenter sur le
marché local
ces productions pays et de permettre aux
réunionnais de choisir en fait entre eux
les productions pays et les productions
de l'import en sachant que aujourd'hui
les pollutions pays-bas vous avez des
produits de saison des produits de
qualité c'est une aide forfaitaire de
4000 euros par an et par exploitation
agricole qui peut être portée à 8000
euros ce condition de produire au moins
une tonne de en production cumulée d'ail
ou d'oignons après à l'avenir c'est
d'acquérir peut-être une laveuse une
boîte l'aise pour pour moins cher avec
l'aide je pense que ça va savoir donner
un coup de pouce supplémentaire
ce dispositif des aides concernent onze
produits de consommation courante
majoritairement importés
la tomate l'oignon l'ail la carotte la
pomme de terre le chou les agrumes la
fraise le piment le curcuma et le
gingembre
[Musique]